you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is round 8
from the 2014 Sinquefield Cup between
Fabiano Caruana playing as white and
magnus carlsen going into this round
Caruana remains perfect with 7 out of 7
and Carlson has 4 out of 7 so let's see
what took shape in this one and let's
see if someone can finally put an end to
this perfect streak so Caruana opening
with e4 in this one Carlsen replying
with the Sicilian Knight f3 knight c6 I
have an open Sicilian with the d4 and
now g6 enters a dragon structure see for
Roxy bind having now a grip over both d5
and b5 the to pawn breaks for black so
Knight f6 Knight c3 to defend e4 keep in
mind that there's no worry on the black
side of white taking on c6 and pushing
the knight around
Queen a5 would win the pawn so it's nice
c3 d6 and now
f3 this Bishop wants to play to e3 but
playing there immediately would allow
Knight g4 to kick the bishop so f3
secures the bishops position and well
before the bishop can be in a position
to defend the knight on d4 black
captures announce the Queen who gets to
recapture or who is forced to recapture
and she seems very well placed but this
is only short-lived since after Bishop
g7 Bishop e3 and castles now there's the
threat of Knight g4 throwing a punch at
both the Queen and Bishop so she needs
to find a new home Queen d2 is best
playing somewhere else such as d3 runs
into these types of tempo gaining moves
so it's Queen d2
now a five this looks to eventually
induce some queenside weaknesses in the
white camp and in this game it turns out
to being the c-4 square some drawbacks
related to the a5 advance are that both
the b6 + b5 are weakened and well with
b5 weekend we can be sure that this idea
of a b5 pawn break is ruled out so
that's one of the downsides with
disadvantage it's B 3 a 4 and now B 4
keep in mind Knight takes a four shot
down Knight takes e4 and there goes your
rook so you can't do this move b4 was
played if you're doing something other
than b4 here such as rook b1 well you're
making life too easy for the black rook
he has exactly what he would want a
completely open file so White's going to
make that more difficult
b4 this file now remains closed he's
going to have to work a little harder to
get active and with b4 we have now the
c-4 square that's a bit soft and at the
same time c5 is also being controlled
and so there can maybe at some point be
a new possibility on the white side
namely a c5 pawn break okay so Bishop e6
quite logical to put pressure on the
weakest point in the white camp this is
a common reorganization of pieces by the
way or I should state it as we will
often see the bishop play to e6 when we
have this King side fianchetto this out
of this dragon structure we'll see the
bishop often play to e6 to not only
watch over a knight hopping into d5 but
in this case of course to put pressure
on c4 and to now allow the knight to a
drop back to d7 and notice
there could be some instances where as
soon as not saying in this exact
position but if this bishop is not first
placed on e6 and this Knight tries to go
for some maneuver with d7 or b6 or
somewhere else you'll notice that the d5
square would not be guarded but by
playing your Bishop to e6 first it's a
little role reversal the bishop is there
to watch over d5 strike at c4 now I
could a bit more freely play this Knight
d7 move without any concern of Knight to
d5
again I'm not referencing it in this
exact position but just the idea there
is of course this tactic that would be
available if white is playing Knight to
d5 right away okay
well in reply to Bishop e6 it was rook
c1 quite good getting it in a spot out
of the line of fire for one and there to
watch over c4 in comes Knight d7 bit
should be - Knight b6 consistent putting
more pressure on c4 and even more
pressure is right around the corner
with rook c8 White's there to defend
Knight b5 is one of one way you can
defend c4 the one that may even be more
natural looking is to centralize the
knight to allow both pieces to defend to
allow the rook to defend and just block
any pressure by the bishop but notice
one of the differences or maybe the main
difference between both of these squares
Knight b5 is not so welcome to peace
exchanges whereas 95 maybe is can have
these Knights come off at any moment
white keep in mind has that space
advantage maybe wants to keep three
pairs of minor pieces on the board
Knight b5 comes with an additional idea
in the game we had Carlson playing a
three and one of the main ideas behind
this is to stop white from playing
Knight to a3 you'll notice if black in
this position played rook c8 like and
play Knight a3 seems quite odd to
retreat the night like this and throw
them on the edge of the board but he's
serving a very good role that of
watching over c4 and with this point
secure where exactly is blacks active
plan will it be b5 don't see that
happening d5 nope
f5 that's probably it
if I'm to take this just a little bit
further suppose Knight d7 and castles
let's say f5 is in and many of these
videos I'll often talk about pawn
majorities especially the ones in the
center the current situation black has a
2-0 advantage but it's hard to really
see these ponds as being an advantage
for black it's not as if they are
further advanced on the fifth-ranked the
route they really are not posing any
threat to the white side in such a
position okay well after Knight to b5
this Knight was never even given an
option to drop into a three to defend c4
because black plays a three ruling this
out and also with an idea of playing
Knight a four to drop into b2 or maybe
even c3 Bishop and Knight are well
coordinated knight on a four and that
Bishop over here on g7 I up these B 2
and C 3 squares so okay Knight d4 hits
the bishop he drops back and now h4 and
with this 17th move more quickly
reminded as a viewer of this game that
play doesn't necessarily have to take
place on the Queen side alone that's
where we had a lot of the action up into
this point but
with h4 this is something we would see
out of the Sicilian dragon Yugoslav
attack where the King is residing over
here on the Queen side he's still in the
center but maybe this is a quite okay
home maybe he could simply step up to f2
and before you know this other rook can
being getting over to the H file if it
is to open up so very aggressive
intentions with this H form of looking
for h5 and to peel open the H file these
other ideas spring to mind of removing
the dark square bishop and going right
for that black Kings throat so lack of
course sees this idea playing h5 like
we'll have to work harder to get some
break-in in white does so g4 must open
up the G file and/or H file black has to
do something about that capturing on g4
F takes G both sides of the board are
being made use of we saw a lot of action
early on on the Queen side with these
pawn advances before some pressure on
the c4 point but now the attention well
we have to pay a little bit more
attention of course or maybe our primary
focus needs to be over here on the Kings
side one wrong slip and that could be it
primary primarily for black I believe
they're the side who has to be much more
cautious with this rook ready to become
active on the H file after an h5 break
so black needs to strike do something
active here be direct with play e5 is
the move not one that you really want to
make not a move you want to make because
well you can forget about this bishop
looking at any of these Queen side
squares he decreases in his activity but
I think it's very important to dislodge
this Knight from the d4 square the ideal
post for a knight and one this Knight
right here is one who can simply drop a
hammer on the position if given the
opportunity if
this night is not kicked from his strong
post he can very well play into a square
you didn't think possible such as f5
this is a common piece sacrifice you
need to be aware of on the black side
dropping the knight in to f5 in a timely
manner for example let's say the night
is not dislodged from his strong post
suppose something as natural looking as
rip to see a half-open file okay well we
can play as blood as white Bishop to h6
looking to remove the main defender of
this King and if you're trying to now
kick the knight one move later with e5 I
am in no way saying this is best but you
can give strong consideration to this
Knight to f5 move this if you can't see
it in the video but the evaluation is
somewhere around a half pawn advantage
for white and that's being down in this
position a minor piece and only having a
pawn to show for it my main point here
is just to recognize that this is a
potentially deadly move in the game so
he needs to be dealt with immediately
he needs to be kicked from d4
immediately v5 is it knight Knight to f5
in this position it's not not nearly as
effective as it would be one move later
with the bishop being on the h6 Square
already so we don't have that it's not
Knight f5 instead Knight b3 this Knight
has taken quite the journey if you're
keeping track he deployed to c3 b 5 d 4
b3 and eventually he gets to that a5
square okay so the follow-up is Bishop
c6 pointing at the weak point efore and
now Bishop f3 simply there to defend and
one interesting note that Caruana
pointed out after the game he was asked
did he consider Bishop d3 and he wanted
to play to f3 to have the idea of later
playing Bishop to g4 he was at this
point anticipating
five the move that was played in the
game and we can a bit more clearly see
this idea because after G takes f G
takes f as soon as this pawn captures or
moves forward sure enough this bishop
will be on a fast track to get to g4 and
maybe a later east six with check or
even this f5 square so that's a just an
interesting point that I came across or
when he was being interviewed after the
game
d3 would not have that g4 square
available of course
so in reply to that pressure was Bishop
f3 f5 takes takes and now Knight a5
looking to scoop up that Bishop now f4
shutting down the position a bit trying
to keep it a bit closed for this King to
be safe Bishop drops back Knight a for
looking at these this square right here
b2 and as the follow-up Knight takes
Bishop there was a another option black
had in this position instead of f4 and
that was to meet Knight to a5 with
taking the knight something that I don't
like I don't know that you could really
justify this type of exchange sacrifice
these these pieces here are all going to
be working very soon the ones who are
not working really well in this position
are the knight on a four and the rook on
c1 there are open files in the position
and I believe both rooks will be quick
to make use of those open files as a
follow up in this position if we did
have this idea by black to take the
knight and then drop the knight into a
four we could have Bishop g5 if black is
reacting we can now have rook g1 and
then looking to get this Bishop involved
with Bishop to h5 and again these four
pieces are all contributing this is the
only rook and not doing
great deal neither's this night however
I believe white is the preferred side
again I'm not really seeing the benefit
for going in in for that exchange
sacrifice so Carlson didn't go down that
road it was not rook takes Knight but
rather Knight a for I'm sorry f4 for his
Bishop f2 and now Knight a for Knight
takes Bishop pawn takes Knight White has
the bishop pair
welcome to of course the position
opening up and now white castles the
move this move here struck me as a bit
odd I was thinking about King to e2 in
this position the computer cries out for
it well I don't know cries out but one
of the moves that it's considering his
h5 I was thinking more along the lines
of King to e2 as being a perfectly good
home for the King well maybe that's a
stretch to see say perfectly good but I
didn't really see a way that this Knight
can cause the King any problems and I
didn't see away or at least I'm not
seeing a way that another black piece
can get involved to try to dislodge the
King's position on he to I think that
this is a pretty safe home and it allows
for the other rope to get involved over
here on the g1 square we didn't have
that instead white castled staying far
away from the knight he's certainly not
going to bother the white king and now
we have b5 which is a bit of a curious
move to see because at first glance here
of course giving up this d5 square and
that would come with check the give and
take with this move is well you give up
d5 for maybe a timely check but at the
same time you're allowing this knight to
eventually make use of b6 where he can
put pressure on c4 black needs to get
this Knight working he's a dead piece
over here on the edge and the action is
still related to the Kings side of the
board attacking one anothers King
so after c5
was b5 white has disconnected past pawn
something that would increase in value
as the as we approach an endgame
especially if it turns into a King and
pawn endgame so Bishop f6 is the follow
up King h1 with King h1 this pawn on h4
is indirectly defended in the game we
had Knight b6 if this pawn is taken
there would follow rook g1 and now rook
g2 with the main idea to place this rook
on h2 and get this inactive rook finally
contributing over here on g1 what's
maybe best on the black side is to play
rook f7 but what follows as Bishop takes
Bishop rook h7 rook h2 and after rook
takes h4 there is now Queen f2 and this
is a disaster for black if rook takes
rook Queen takes and we're going to be
having mate very soon okay well we
didn't have that after King to h1 it was
not Bishop takes pawn again he is
indirectly defended this pawn you might
also view it as a good defender for the
black king he at least will find shelter
over here on the H file for as long as
he's around okay in the game it was
Knight b6 rook on C to D one a better
play would have been to
the rook on f2d won by playing the rook
on C 2 D 1 this this point here is a bit
soft something that cannot be taken
right away because of Queen d5 and the
knight would be one but at a later stage
in the game one that's not long off from
now that C pawn drops this would have
been a better move rook on F to d1 and
how do you meet the threat against d6
and could you at this point get away
with taking on h4 no you cannot because
of these similar ideas with rook g1 and
a rook lift to follow with both rooks
getting involved against an attack
against the king so after rook F to d1
this pawn would still be immune from
being captured parent best is Bishop e7
but this allows Bishop takes c5 cute
little tactic if pawn takes Bishop we're
not going to take the Queen we're going
to come over here to G to throw a check
and then there goes the Queen it's a
slick little move right there
neat little tactic it should take c5
Queen scoots over and there goes your
queen so it was not rook F to D 1
instead rook C to D 1 and now King h8
Queen takes d6 Queen takes Queen rook
takes Queen Knight takes e4 and now rook
to d5 what we're going to enter right
now is an opposite color Bishop ending
after Knight e3 that lands a fork he
needs to be taken out so as Bishop takes
Knight pawn takes and now Bishop to e2
eventually what happens is that this
position simplifies quite a bit both
rooks end up getting exchanged and with
just the bishops on board there's not
much fight left in the game a better
play for this rook at this point right
here after the Knight takes on c4 would
be to play to the 7th with the ID
if the night drops into e3 you can take
him out and now this B pond is very
threatening ready to play the b7 with
tempo just a single Square way from
queening and black will find it much
more difficult to defend this position
as an example if route b8 there is b7
and if brick g8 you have to try to get
rid of this rook somehow rook and g8
looks to do just that getting him off of
the seventh rank there could be rook b1
Bishop takes h4 rook c7 this is as far
as I want to take it I just want to
highlight how dangerous this pawn could
be being a single square away coupled
width of rook on the 7th is very very
effective you're not just restricting by
having this pawn on b7 you're not just
restricting to the rook on b8 to being
very passive but also the rook over here
on g8 both rooks and one might even
reason the king are all very passive
being cut off
if this rook is to go elsewhere off of
the eighth-ranked there's always these
ideas of rook - seeing that type of
tactic so having this right here these
two pawns are I'm sorry the pawn in the
rook on the seventh rank you really
restrict both rooks and King it's a very
strong position for white we didn't have
that in this position after Knight takes
e4 was not rook d7 not placing the rook
on the seventh but rather rook d5 and
now Knight e3 Bishop takes Knight pawn
takes opposite color bishops material is
not necessarily as important in these
types of endings Bishop e2 Bishop takes
h4 rook f5 if this rook is going to be
taken white will have another pass pawn
like sees that as being quite alright
takes pawn takes both sides have passed
pawns these guys over here on the a file
offset rook d8 and now the rooks are
exchanged and this one will quickly
dwindling if something other than
exchanging this last these last rooks
here if Ruki five well this rook is now
very active rook d2 can happen and if
white isn't careful white can drop the
a2 pun and maybe this pawn becomes very
scary being just two squares away from
queening and keep in mind either side
queening here would be coming at this
stage right here with check if something
such as Bishop to c4 there can follow
rook d4 if Bishop b3 if Bishop b3 there
could be c4 White has to be very careful
in this position if he is in other words
to avoid the rook exchange rook takes
pawn again he gets very active so white
apparently saw it best to exchange rooks
Kings need to get involved and again
material isn't going to be so necessary
right here that pawn push giving him up
just so the bishop can now play to b6
this pawn is now defended equal material
after Bishop to d3 is at this point that
the players agreed to a draw so a very
good fight this lat this final position
right here if we look at the pawns they
offset one another there's not much
progress to be made a bishop on d3
he's watching over this pawn from
advancing so he's restricted if we look
at the dark square bishop he's
performing two functions a to stop the
pond from advancing and B to watch over
the pond the White King he's stopping
the black pond from advancing he's
watching over upon the black King is
performing two functions to defend the
pond and stop the white pond from
advancing so every piece in this
position is
restricted in some way and it's very
difficult to come up with any active
plan the only active plan at this point
in the game is for white to try
something like King to d5 and then after
Bishop to d4 king c6 there can follow
efore can't take the pawn because this
guy promotes so Bishop e2 King takes f5
again this is just showing you this to
highlight one active plan in the
position but this this two would end as
a draw the bishop ends up getting one
but at the end of it this King and pawn
ending is going to be a draw you just
basically mimic the black King at this
point a1 c1 a2 c2 and if the black King
does or if the black side to something
else like a - well that's stalemate but
as it was in this game after this very
interesting struggle Bishop to d3 it's
at this point they agreed to a draw and
with that the streak stops it had to
come to an end at some point
and it was certainly a very good run and
with that Caruana ends up winning the
Sinquefield Cup 2014 still with two
rounds to go again I've said it time and
time again it's really really impressive
stuff two rounds to go already clinched
it and with that the $100,000 top prize
so that's all for this video as always I
hope you got something out of it take
care bye
you
[Music]